a seventh home threatened by a massive
sinkhole in Florida has been condemned
at its widest the crater measures 260
feet that is larger than the wingspan of
a Boeing 747 it first appeared more than
three weeks ago and destroyed two homes
Manuel Bojorquez is in land o lakes
florida outside tampa where it could
take months to make the area around the
sinkhole safe and well good morning good
morning this is as close as authorities
will let us get to the sinkhole and to
all the work that is being done in this
area you can see there's a lot of
activity right now only allowing us this
close for security reasons but we can't
show you what it looked like earlier
this morning from above it is widened by
another 30 feet since last week no
deaths or injuries have been reported
but crews have not been able to finish
stabilizing its banks or even clearing
the debris officials described this
mammoth sinkhole now filled with water
as the largest in the county in 30 years
it swallowed two homes in this Tampa
suburb when it suddenly appeared July 14
after it widened again over the weekend
five more houses were condemned and even
more families were displaced the news
that we're not gonna be able to go back
in ever to the house is sad but it
offers closure
it's not safe to live in the county
found cracked walls are an unstable
foundation in the houses it wants
demolished this is a catastrophic
financial event for some people these
are people's nest eggs their their homes
sometimes is the biggest investment they
may have officials say they don't know
if the recent instability means the
sinkhole is still growing or if it a
grated existing depressions nearby that
area was a lake before and who knows
maybe it's going to become a lake in the
future as part of the first phase of the
cleanup crews dumped 125 truckloads of
uncrushed Lime Rock on the edge of the
giant hole to keep the banks from
collapsing next waste trucks will pump
out contaminated water while a backhoe
floating on a barge removes debris from
the center of the sinkhole some
residents remain uncooked
putting dirt in it and the dirt is gonna
the county contractor expects to clean
up to be done in ten days at a cost of
about a million dollars
Margaret Manny we can hear that they are
hard at work all around you there good
job competing with that truck